concentration willpower practice yes
although say important dose of the
ingredients but how much do you want it
a monk that tells you is never quest in
the path are never thought of leaving is
lighting we live our lives like we're
gonna live forever
but the truth is we don't live forever
need motivation whattcha top 10 with
belief nation
what's that belief nation it 7 this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and join today's lessons from a
man who went from graduating with a
degree in electrical engineering to
leaving it all behind to become a Hindu
monk and living in a monastery in Hawaii
for 10 years he's done the pani and
here's my take on his top 10 rules of
success
okay let's kick it up with rule number
one wanted bad enough a good friend of
mine is an illusion who want a gold
medal in netball I ain't rolling no
sorry no beach ball beach volleyball and
so I interviewed her in Australia a
couple of months ago when we're talking
about it and I said what drove you to
win yeah and most people don't want it
enough you know and if people ask me you
know it's like how do you go to Monster
how you leave your family behind your
friends everything ice cream chocolate
yeah
Beach you know go anything that you can
imagine and go to the monster for 10
years yeah no contact because you want
it it just comes down to how much you
really wanted well concentration
willpower practice yes all those so
important those are the ingredients but
how much do you want it if you really
really want it you make it work but most
people don't want it enough yeah my
teacher used to say to me all the time
if you want something new you have to
give up something older yeah was sitting
on the couch in if you want to bring a
brand-new couching it would have to get
rid of this and sacrifice is such a good
thing you have to give up the always
your different thing parts of your life
in order to gain something new but you
have to want it you really really have
to want it and that's why they go from
one self-help book to another cell phone
book which another self-help book and
they say well you're not picking the
best pots out of here and then it's like
a buffet you know you just pick what you
want and you never commit to anything
find one thing commit to it and be an
expert rule number two have clear goals
a month Patel's he's never questioned
the path I never thought of leaving is
lying to you
okay even though I wanted to be amongst
in size 4 I thought many times of
leaving and not wanting to do it but use
a stick to it because that's what you
love it's I'm sure when you're running
the race at that point
want to quit every race I do all right
yeah it's crazy yeah we lay out
everything I get it yeah so it's the
same way as well this just the thought
comes up and you just go like but this
is what this is you write your the
racing you see being being monkish me
there's little crickets there get in
your head and those crickets are telling
you right you're on the wrong path and
you gotta get rid of them
yeah and it's I think it's just being
crystal clear of what you want in life
right from the start
yeah and then just having that willpower
and the perseverance to to follow it
through and be unwavering in that in
your commitment and your TrueNorth and
yeah where you want to go well you know
I think they yeah I think most people
get swayed it's because they don't
really know what they want in life and
if you ask most people what they want in
life they say I want to be happy and
happiness is not a goal a presidency at
all yeah it's a byproduct of something
right if if I eat ice cream or drink
here I might feel happy but it's not a
goal to be pursued and I think that's
why people get off the path so often is
because they don't know where they're
going
rule number three uplift others how do
you keep this first and all you have to
face up when life gets you down and your
goals seem far away this is a very
challenging thing v-dog quite often when
we're feeling down it's not so easy to
uplift ourselves and sometimes we can
kind of get stuck in that funkiness
funky area of the mind just wallow in
that sorrow so to speak and one of the
things that my gurus to recommend to me
just a man in general anybody that asked
him to help him get out of a place of
funkiness of feeling down is to uplift
somebody else so what he would say is
you uplift yourself by uplifting someone
else and that was kind of the essence of
the message you lift yourself but with
lifting somebody else find a friend
uplift them you can uplift them by doing
something nice for them something that
you know they need help with or are they
need in their life but they may not have
asked you but you know by you offering
your health and just doing it for them
would make a big difference in their
life reach out and do that for them and
as you provide them with the selfless
service and act of love you up with the
experts and I see a cliff desperate you
know cliff to you so this is something
that works really really well something
that I've done myself and continue to do
whenever I'm feeling a little down on a
funky place I'll do that I'll find
somebody that I can uplift and I just
uplifting them I find myself being
uplifted as well rule number four
control your awareness I think
understanding the - one of the most
important things anybody could do it's I
always tell people that's the one thing
that we don't have a manual for
everything else in life we get a manual
right yeah your clothing has manual
there's a tag in the back tells you how
to wash it
yeah food blenders come with manuals
cameras but the mine doesn't and from
among experiential learning the best the
simplest way to understand the - to
understand the difference between
awareness and the mind so imagine your
minor as a map with different areas some
areas of your mind that's angry happy
sad jealousy odd signs food sex sports
and awareness is a glowing ball of light
that floats around in your mind and
where it goes in your mind it lights up
that area when it lights up that area
you become conscious of it so yo
awareness this glowing ball of light is
always being pulled from one area of the
mind to another by people and things
around you yet true that notification
goes off you know awareness goes to
trigger of the
you see a facebook notification those
well awareness goes over there and then
the phone rings then awareness goes over
here so all day people allow people and
things around them to pull their
awareness for one thing to another once
you learn how to control the mind you
really not controlling their mind you're
controlling awareness and where
awareness goes in the mind now you can
keep allowing us on one thing at a time
and remain concentrated so now how can
we get control that way and so how can
we practice to get better at controlling
our work the best way to do this is to
integrate the practice into everyday
life so I feel that if you're practicing
just example meditation in the morning
for 15 minutes a half an hour is
completely useless if the remaining 23
and a half hours of the day you're doing
something that's common productive yeah
so I believe the best way to make
progress the most efficient way to make
progress is to actually integrate the
practice into everything that you're
doing yeah
so for example every time you speak with
your lovely spouse give her your
undivided attention so keep the
awareness on your spouse if the
awareness drifts away bring your
awareness back to your spouse it drifts
away again bring it back to you suppose
yeah so with everything you do keep your
hands on them do one thing at a time and
the more you practice the better you get
at it
rule number five surround yourself with
success you find yourself in New York
the world is ending financial crisis
yeah and there's probably a lot of Wall
Street people at that moment that need
need a monk yeah probably
is that who you that that your customer
base like who do you start sitting with
to try to help them mainly entrepreneurs
so I didn't know very much about
business and I went to destroy myself at
financially successful entrepreneurs so
I started using some tools to create it
in my mind and surround myself with
successful entrepreneurs and I just
haven't yeah you start attracting people
if you start to change the shape of your
mind you know by using some techniques
you start attracting like-minded people
into your life today and so the first
one comes the second one comes before
you know you're the center of your
entrepreneurial network two things one
is I wanted to work with that group of
people second is I wanted to build a
business that's successful and where do
I start I figured I could go to business
school forget that all in from someone
who's done it and done it really well so
I chose the second option and I
if I surrounded myself with these people
I could just learn from them and believe
in in the power of a community rule
number six get clarity no one's died
going to the other side taking a selfie
come back posted it on Instagram go look
at me here in heaven hashtag pearly
gates right no we don't know we have our
beliefs and some of us hold strong to
our beliefs but we really don't know
what happens at the point of that so
most of us don't like to think about it
so we live our lives like we're gonna
live forever but the truth is we don't
live forever
you've never seen a 500 year old man or
a thousand year old woman we've been
evolving on this planet for about
million two million years we all die at
some point when you realize that life is
finite it's not short and you see this
cute little throats on Instagram saying
life is short be happy I think that's
wrong life is not short life is actually
a very very long but it's definitely
finite there's a definitive end to it
for sure when you realize that life is
finite you become clear of all of a
sudden who and what's important in your
life
rule number seven push hard to get
things done a lot of times people say
when life is balanced it's a straight
life I think life is a sine wave yeah
you know and sometimes you have to push
really hard especially if you're an
entrepreneur yeah you know there's a
certain time in your business where
you're really pushing hard to get
something done there in the last three
months has been like that for me I try
to change my business model then get a
lot of things done so I'm really pushing
quite out of balance but if you always
know what you call put of us a life is
and then you know where to come back to
push for one two three months and then
come back to your purpose
rule number key be focused my goal was
to to have my own business to be an
entrepreneur and make my own money and I
had you've been thinking about it while
you're in the monastery yeah the last
well not all those years the last couple
years deciding whether I wanted to leave
us probably the woman say probably was
the hardest decision I've ever made in
my life was to leave the monastery yeah
so the next question would be what would
I do you know could I ran a web business
from the monastery
we we had the largest web site in the
state of Hawaii really yeah monks
program in HTML CSS JavaScript and we
were trained how to edit movies on Final
Cut Pro design and InDesign Photoshop we
we knew it inside out Wow
yeah I I learned coding in the monastry
oh that's awesome I didn't know well I
thought I literally thought you were
preparing for meditation we we took
those concentration skills into
everything that we did so when we were
programming we focused on programming
you know when we we were building a
building we were pouring cement on the
sidewalk or sweeping something or
cooking we're focused so in everything
that we did throughout the day we
practiced all the tools that we learned
so when we sat to meditate we'd been
practicing for 23 hours all day rule
number nine walk away from energy
vampires I have several people in my
life friends and relatives but I want to
support but after I spend time with them
my field trained
sometimes I avoid them but then I feel
guilty and can only avoid them for so
long can you explain why I feel this way
and what advice you have for me
thank you very person Erica and I think
this is something that a lot of people
face and are not sure how to approach
basically I mean the way to look at it
is that we only have so much energy each
day when we go to sleep we wake up in
the morning we have for example this
much energy and corrupt the day we we
use that energy we give that energy to
people and things around us and by the
end of the day that energy gets less and
less and less and then till the end of
the day where
almost nothing left and you feel tired
and you go to sleep again so one of the
things you have to understand is that
some people fill you with energy and
some people drain you of energy the
people that drain you of energy I'd like
to call them energy vampires and there
are a lot of them and sometimes these
people colleagues their friends their
relatives even close family members one
of the important things to do is really
identify someone is their temporary
energy vampire are they inherently an
energy vampire so what I mean by that is
so what is temporarily an energy vampire
I mean that they're going through a
difficult time in their life if somebody
in the family has died or going through
a divorce or some big challenging
experience and for a few months so maybe
a couple of years yeah energetically
draining but it's okay you know you love
them did a friend a family member you
want to support them and you can put up
with that for a little time in your life
like someone is inherently an energy
vampire you know they've always been
their whole life every time you meet
with them you encounter them you feel
completely drained and it's really
important to take note of that
that's a personality trait that's not
going to change anytime soon unless
they're actively working on it and most
energy most energy vampires don't really
want to work on themselves in nature so
one of the things to do here at this
point is to identify these people one of
the ways to identify these people is
that when you spend time with someone
and as soon as you've had a conversation
or the damn log - spending time with
them when you walk away as soon as you
turned around in the walkway ask
yourself do you feel uplifted I do you
feel drained and that's immediately
you'll know as soon as you turn around a
lock where you feel uplifted you're
going oh that was such a great
conversation I got so much out of they
feel so inspired you know then that
there's an uplifted you but if you walk
away and you feel completely draining
you are cut off so exhausting
then chances are that person is an
energy vampire and especially if you
meet that person
15 20 times a year and to see you met
that person 20 times a year and out of
the 20 times a year 19 of those be
extremely exhausting conversations then
you think white very well-qualified you
can easily qualify that that person is
an energy vampire
and you want to avoid them you don't
really want people in your life the way
you look at it is that if you're working
so hard on yourself to improve yourself
to be a better person and then what
allows someone else to come and dream
your way it's for example an
entrepreneur with who builds his
business from nothing would never allow
somebody to come in and destroy his
business right you just wouldn't do that
so the same way you've worked so hard to
uplift yourself and be a better human
being why would you allow somebody to
come and train you and rule number ten
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is meditate I believe in I've been
trained to have a goal every time you
sit down to meditate you should really
have a goal like for example when you
get in the car put on your seat belt and
start the engine to dry somewhere you
have a destination alright you just
don't get into cons start driving so the
same way when you sit down to meditate
there should be a destination that
should be something that you're reaching
for what is that goal what is that
purpose it's totally up to you really
comes down to what you use meditation
for in the tradition that I come from
that I belong to meditation is a tool
that has many purposes but the ultimate
purpose in our tradition at least is to
attain self-realization or enlightenment
some people just use meditation for
relaxation to relieve stress for all
kinds of things so you set your own goal
for meditation but the key point that
I'm trying to make is that every
meditation should have a goal and a
purpose once you've said your goal the
method and practice that you should that
you have should be systematic and
practical it should be a clear system on
getting from A to B in your meditation
it should never be random it should
never be different every single day the
practice should be the same take a very
simple mundane example so for example if
you're going to take a shower before you
take a shower you take your clothes off
you turn the water on you make sure it's
the right temperature you jump in the
shower you get wet you put soap on you
watch the soap ball if you like yourself
dry and then you put your fresh clothes
on you never mix that order up you just
don't do
you do that same order every single day
so the same way with meditation as well
you figure out the goal that you want to
get to you figure out a systematic step
and process to its getting that and you
do that every day now I've got a really
special bonus down the Piney clip on how
to deal with stress that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or in your
business so answer these three questions
question number one what are three clear
goals that you want to accomplish
question number two what can you do
today to uplift somebody and question
number three what will you add to your
morning routine to surround yourself
with success
I had met my guru when I was about 21
and I was going to join his monastic
order which was in Hawaii I was at that
time living in Western Australia and
studying in University and I remembered
my last year of engineering I was
feeling extremely stressed I had a
thesis which I've been working on for a
year and a half that I needed to
complete in the next month I had seven
or eight examinations that I had to pass
in order to graduate as an engineer I
was the president of the youth group of
a temple over that local temple over
there and they're organizing a lot of
different events and I was also dancing
as part of a dance company that I was
involved in and they were also putting
up a big show so we were rehearsing
almost every night and I remember you
nailing my guru saying
Gurudeva I'm really stressed I have all
these things going on and I'm stressed
he emailed me back and I don't remember
the exact words that he he used but he
emailed me back and said the reason
you're stressed is because you don't
keep you awareness on one thing at a
time and I'll be absolutely honest with
you ever since that they have never felt
stressed anymore and I know it's a very
bold Proclamation to make but it's true
cuz I clearly understood what he said to
me at that point whenever I was dancing
I was thinking about my thesis and I was
working on my thesis I was thinking
about the exams I had to do and I was
thinking on my exams when I was studying
for my exams I was thinking about the
youth group and wherever I was I was
thinking about something else
anxiety comes because we allow us to
drift away from the present moment and
go into the future or into the past in
an uncontrolled way so the past and the
future are not bad things as long as we
indulge in them or we entered and with
the aim to learn
them but we don't if we just allow
awareness to travel into the past into
the future all the time it creates
anxiety and we do that because we're
friend anxiety comes out of a sense of
fear where we allow us to go into the
future we create a situation that hasn't
happened we bring it back into the
present and start living it as it has
already happened you keep repeating the
process over and over and over again you
buildings I I'm gonna get sick I'm gonna
get sick you think in the future what if
I get sick then what happens oh my god
I'm gonna get sick of you being back to
present and you start living back five
minutes later you let your awareness go
into the future you think to yourself
I'm not gonna get better I'm gonna get
sick and then you bring the way let's
back into the present again and you
start worrying about it you keep
repeating this process over and over
again and you're billing tithing so the
way to get overcome stress and anxiety
is to really control where your hands
goes every time your awareness goes into
the future into the past in an
uncontrolled way bring it back to the
present again and just do this exercise
be mindful of this throughout the entire
day don't let your awareness go into the
pasta all into the future in an
uncontrolled way raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
mm-hmm that people your passion and not
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
if you want to learn from another man
who went from being a monk to a speaker
and coach I highly recommend my Jay
Shetty top ten rules a success the link
is right next to me I will see you there
hey Ivan and everyone watching thank you
so much for featuring my ideas and my
thoughts